foreign
the essence of being human is that we
solve problems
and when we're faced with enormous
problems like disease and climate change
we need to solve them by collaboration
I'm excited to tell you about a new kind
of collaboration that will absolutely
create solutions to these big problems
it's a collaboration that's unexpected
because it's between humans and the
tiniest organisms that populate our
planet the bacteria and other microbes
that live in on and around us
bacteria may be small and unseen but
they often have inspired transformative
Innovations including the one that has
become the Cornerstone of my own
research
over the past decade I've been at the
Forefront of developing a revolutionary
technology called crispr
that has come from the study of how
bacteria fight viral infection
crispr is amazing because it allows us
to precisely edit the DNA in living
organisms including in people and plants
with crispr we can change remove or
replace the genes that govern the
function of cells
this means that we now have the ability
to use crispr like a word processor to
find cut and paste text
crispr amazingly has already cured
people of devastating disorders like
sickle cell disease and it's created
rice plants that are resistant to both
diseases and drought incredible right
but the next world-changing Advance with
crispr will actually come from using it
in a way that will allow us to go to the
next level by editing genes Beyond just
in individual organisms we now have the
ability to use crispr to edit entire
populations of tiny microbes called
microbiomes that live in and on our
bodies
for decades scientists studied bacteria
one organism at a time as if each type
of bacteria behaved independently but we
now know that bacterial behavior is both
good and bad result from their
interactions within complex microbiomes
in humans dysfunctional gut microbiomes
are associated with diseases as diverse
as Alzheimer's and Asthma and in farm
animals microbiomes produce methane a
powerful contributor to climate change
but when they're healthy both human and
animal microbiomes can actually prevent
disease and reduce methane emissions so
to harness these benefits we need a way
to precisely and reproducibly control
these microbial communities
so why are microbiomes been difficult to
control in the past
it turns out that you know microbiomes
are very complex and they're difficult
to manipulate antibiotics affect the
entire microbiome and they they're
overused can lead to drug resistance
diet and probiotics are non-specific and
they're they're uh they're often
ineffective
fecal transplants
phase various challenges to both
Effectiveness and acceptance
but with crispr we have a tool that
works like a scalpel it allows us to
Target a particular Gene in a particular
kind of cell with crispr we can change
one kind of
bacterium without affecting all the
others
another challenge is that less than one
percent of the world's microbial species
have been grown and studied in the lab
fortunately we can now access the other
99 percent due to the pioneering
research of my colleague Jill Banfield
and her breakthrough technology
metagenomics
which is a tool that allows us to figure
out what species are present and what
they're doing in a microbial community
metagenomics creates a detailed
blueprint of a complex microbiome and
that means that we can use it to figure
out how to use Gene editing tools in the
right Gene in the right organism
you might be wondering how we can take
this new knowledge and harness it to
solve real world problems
well we're bringing together these two
breakthrough Technologies metagenomics
and crispr to create a brand new field
of science called precision
microbiomediting
this will allow us to discover links
between dysfunctional microbiomes and
disease or greenhouse gas emissions we
can develop modified and improved
microbiome editors and show that they're
safe and effective
and then we can then begin to deploy
these optimized solutions to create the
kinds of solutions that will be
transformative in the future
so how does this affect our health and
the health of our planet we know the
poorest countries and people are the
most affected by climate change and it's
a problem created by the wealthiest
people and methane is a big part of the
problem it's been a major contributor to
Rising global temperatures since
pre-industrial times
specific microbiome compositions and
livestock can actually reduce methane
emissions by up to 80 percent but doing
that today currently requires daily
interventions at enormous expense and it
just doesn't scale
but with Precision microbiome editing we
have an opportunity to modify a calf's
microbiome at it at Birth limiting that
animal's impact on the climate for its
entire lifetime
and this is beneficial for Farmers
because reduced methane production means
more efficient conversion of feed into
food
importantly these tools can be used in
the future to reduce methane emissions
from other sources like landfills
Wastewater and rice paddies
ultimately microbiomes generate up to
two-thirds of all of the methane
emissions globally so our technology
could really move the needle in our
fight against climate change
in human health asthma affects up to 300
million people around the world a number
that grows by 50 percent Each decade and
it disproportionately affects lower
income children
our team has identified a promising link
between a molecule produced in the gut
microbiome and Asthma development
with Precision microbiome editing we
could offer a child at risk for asthma a
non-invasive therapy that would
eliminate asthma inducing molecules
changing her life trajectory
and what's really exciting is that these
same approaches in the future could help
us
treat or even prevent human diseases
that are linked to the gut microbiome
including obesity diabetes and
Alzheimer's
I think it's fascinating that we can now
use crispr to edit the same tiny
organisms that gave us crispr in doing
so we're collaborating with the ultimate
partner nature
together we can use crispr powered
Precision microbiome editing to build a
more resilient future for all of us
thank you very much